let's talk about what's going on with
the freedom convoy in canada which is
going viral it's it's being talked about
everywhere except for mainstream media i
don't know if you've been following this
story or not let's kind of go through a
couple things that's going on there
folks uh hundreds of truckers block
ottawa in freedom convoy to protect to
protest
vaccine mandates it's a france 24 story
hundreds of truckers have
blocked the streets of uh central auto
on saturday as part of the self-entire
self-titled freedom convoy to protest
vaccine mandates required to cross the
u.s border flying a canadian flag waving
banners demanding freedom and chanting
slogans slogans against prime minister
justin trudeau the truckers were joined
by thousands of other protesters angered
not only by the covenanting restrictions
but by uh brother broader discontent
with the government an enormous climb uh
climber ring out of hundreds of big
trucks their engines rumbling sound that
their horns anyways i'm going to tell
you this other store from al jazeera
why are anti-vaccine-canadian truckers
covering
converging in ottawa i like that title
right they're anti-vaccine-canadian
truckers so convoy of antibacks and
canadian truckers and their supporters
making its way to the country's capital
ottawa
uh starting on january 15 canada has
required essential service providers
previously exempt from vaccination
requirements including truck drivers to
be fully vaccinated across the land
brought from the u.s unvaccinated
canadian truck drivers entering the
canada entering canada will need to meet
requirements for pre-entry arrival and
day eight testing as well as quarantine
requirement i keep in mind 90
of these truckers are vaccinated 77 of
the country
is vaccinated and this freedom convoy
co-fund me if you can go to it as of
last night it was at eight point seven
eight point eight million if you just
type in freedom convoy go fund me they
may be over nine million dollars james
i'm assuming you're following you're
following the story what are your
thoughts on what's going on right now
with these truckers
uh you know
9.2 million 9.2 million people 9.2
million dollars raised they haven't
taken it down yet have they taken it
down no they haven't 113 000 donors but
my first surprise is that gofundme has
not taken this down
um
but but i guess that it goes to show you
the difference between how the media
portrays things and how things actually
are because so many of these people in
canada believe in this and it's and it's
self-evident in the pictures you're
seeing like i said pictures evidence you
can see the trucks you can see that
so so they say it's fringe but that's a
characterization that doesn't seem
accurate that doesn't seem based upon
reality does not seem fringe it seems
mainstream it seems that there's a
substantial minority if not majority of
people that agree with these people
so i what what i draw from from this uh
you know this sort of the orwell two
plus duples four quote is that how
things are portrayed by the canadian
leadership and the media
are not as they actually are in in in
terms of the grassroots support for this
adam do you have thoughts on this well
that's what's the ultimate story here
they're just not they're protesting
mandates they're protesting
it comes down mandates some people that
are protesting against a mandate are
fully vaccinated and took the boosters
they're saying i'm fully vaccinated i
just don't want mandates okay so
watching through that mindset they're
basically saying look i did it i support
it i mean
who dr robert malone who you interviewed
is vaccinated yeah he basically said i
almost got crushed by covid yeah if you
can't show that video david if you can
pull up that video so people can see it
however i don't believe
in the mandate ultimately isn't that
what is this picture of here this is
are they wearing math
i don't mean as a judgmental question
are they wearing masks or are they
willing to uh
uh
violate the the city
protocols
so guys the border is 5500 miles long
canada and u.s borders 5 500 miles long
okay you got these truck drivers which
the strangest thing is if anybody cor
their job is to quarantine it's truck
drivers they're by themselves driving
like that it's not like they're around
anybody else they're driving unless
there's 99
of the time unless if you got another
person with you but you're driving
by yourself maybe with another person to
do your job generally
it's by yourself and they're saying if
you don't do this by the 15th to cross
the border to this is not just the
canada thing exactly
crossing the border so that's another
question of the canada to us you're
you're crossing the you know the
international borders make
something my friend laura logan always
says to me which i think is very
poignant and this this is a
visualization of this is really amazing
visuals we're looking here at uh
instagram videos is that they have
tremendous power and we're nothing where
you know that's the comment i see people
say we're nothing we're insignificant
we're nothing but but lara says to me
we're not alone when she says we're not
alone
and and we the people that's it's a
cliche it's a tale as all as time but we
are so insignificant compared to the
powers that be
that have the power of coercion and the
power of the you know the legislatures
but
this is a very amazing moment you know
that that we the people and even
canadians we the people by the way go to
elon musk's tweet because ilamas tweeted
about the truckers and what he said
canadian truckers rule yeah canadian
trucker's rule is what i said yeah
something like that uh so think about it
this way who would have thought kyrie
irving okay
truck drivers in canada
you got elon musk you got
joe rogan you got the strangest camps
that are sitting there saying dude can
we just not be forced to do what you're
telling us to do i'll take the vaccine i
just don't want it before so i had a
couple people over at the house for the
birthday party
and you know some of the guys from the
community very successful business
people and the conversational vaccine
came up from them and i said did you
hear about tom brady what tom brady i'm
like did you hear about truckers what
truckers i'm like you're not following
the story no i'm not following i read
new york times in the wall street
journal journal every day and i've seen
nothing about trucker i'm like you got
to be kidding me zero so they're in
front of me kind of going through it
these are two professionals both of them
are c-suite executives running their
companies living in beautiful property
legit legit people they know nothing
about what's going on and so tell me
about interesting what are your thoughts
on vaccinations what are your thoughts
on this i said listen i think
to each his own i think it's
something that uh probably helps
minimize for certain people my dad had
coveted and he had
pneumonia simultaneously and he had the
covet shot and he was able to go through
it at the age of 79 and he just took the
booster and he's glad to have it right
and then he says how about yourself how
about your employees how about this what
percentage of home office is vaccinated
they're in the health industry i have to
get everybody vaccinated one of my
friends
got all their doctors and nurses and i
like to get them vaccinated 20 of their
employees and doctors just resigned the
city can't force us to do this so there
is a community out there and they're
finding each other and they're sitting
there saying look man i just want you to
leave me alone don't bother me let me do
this by the way in canada things are so
strange in canada because one of the
reporters i don't know if you saw that
james he said look if we have to choose
between keeping you alive and feeding
you
we're going to lean towards keeping you
alive
like what did he should say you know
what he just said if we have to choose
between us not letting these truck
drivers do their job so food is not
being delivered to you these are
thousands these are 15 000 truck drivers
so food doesn't come and you don't have
enough food for a week or two or three
weeks
for us it's more important
to keep you alive from the co from kovit
than feed you
and we have to kind of go through that
and quebec is saying they're going to
start opening up movie theaters with one
rule you can't sell popcorn because they
don't want you to go in without a mask
on because they want nobody eating
popcorn in movie theaters yeah yeah so
it's a very strange dynamic this is what
we talked about last time this is more
than just a health problem there's an
economic problem there's a
social societal problem you're staying
at home you're the depression problem
how many people are not getting out of
the house being able to exercise
you know we we
uh the quote i mean james has been
busting out quotes all day i don't know
who said this but he said war is too
important to be left to just the
generals just like a pandemic is too
scientists there's a lot of business
people there's a lot of
um
just
regular people who have a voice and have
a say
and it's not just one you know one size
fits all type cure to this and and look
what's happening
cb radios are those are the radios that
use for the trucks are free from
censorship control zoom zoom in so we
can the audience can see what he's
radios the truck radios are free for
media control those are the old radios
we grew up in as with kids you know
even um
it's it's a very amazing moment for me
this is all about i go back to the power
of the image i'm going to speak from a
journalistic perspective on this matter
not as a public policy health issue
it's the i it's the idea that those are
profoundly moving images of a convoy of
trucks and thousands hundreds of
thousands of people there are tens of
thousands of people and then the wall
street journal new york times you
wouldn't even know about it
if you lived in manhattan
that's strange if you only read the new
york times yeah if you only you would
not see it
that's actually really an amazing
observation there you wouldn't even know
about it
if you only read certain publications
and that's not right they don't want you
to see why don't they want you to see
the images because they want a
specialized class of men
as edward bernays said and
dean lipman said we need to interpret
the data we don't want you to have the
images because you might draw wrong
conclusions from the images that you see
well that's not right james other than
project veritas obviously what news
sources do you trust any any source that
i can see the evidence myself if it's
your name names
no because it's like no but you're
because a broken clock is right twice a
day i mean anyone can do this any
new york times can and has done good
journalism
but you got to be able to see it like
we're doing right now like we're looking
at the images assuming those images are
not doctored so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]